hey and he has gone you know I'm keeping
busy there's enough stuff to do around
the house I got the dog you know it's
alright yeah it's okay I've tried
cooking a little bit getting a little
better at that but it's starting to feel
pretty old like I'm sick of the
quarantine whoa whoa who's that guy you
guys have got zone bummed suckers Oh No
zoom bombed isn't that where a stranger
interrupts you soon call and starts
posting porn I mean people have been
Zoom bombing classrooms and showing porn
right so important that's disgusting
I know right porn is gross so gross
do not show us any poor and stranger guy
please no porn that wasn't that wasn't
gonna show you any porn why not wait a
minute
how'd you even get our zoom meeting code
Oh somebody posted it on reddit yeah
it's pretty easy to find actually wait
wait go back to the porn thing are you
gonna show us some nasty porn or not uh
no I just wanted to pull a little prank
be on TV I don't have any okay
so you don't have any porn to show us or
you just don't want to show us the porn
no I don't have I don't have any porn on
me to show you like no what is the point
of this you gotta settle down just take
it easy the guys I mean you're telling
me that I want to read it and post it
our zoom
I mean someone posted our zoom number
and we're not even going to get any porn
out of it I don't even like porn okay I
just came here to play a quick little
prank if you want porn go what pornhub
oh do you think I'm an idiot
I know about pornhub I've seen all of it
I thought you I did something new for me
I don't know like a a guy being
breastfed by a bear or something all
right you guys are really creeping me
out I think I need to go spend some time
with my family leave meeting aridif
so you got any plans for the weekend I
am
I mean weekend I think I got to get
going
it's gonna be in another room listen if
anybody out there has any bear stuff
just send it to Dean cocoa care of me
you